the president-elect delivered a grim
message from his base in wilmington
delaware
as i long feared and warned the effort
to distribute and administer the vaccine
is not progressing as it should a few
weeks ago
trump administration suggests that 20
million americans could be vaccinated by
the end of december
with only a few days left in december
we've only vaccinated a few million so
far
and the pace of vaccine the vaccination
program is moving now
as it if he continues to move as it is
now it's going to take years not months
to vaccinate the american people
but joe biden repeated that he had a
comprehensive plan
he would invoke the defense production
act to mandate that the production of
vaccines
and personal protective equipment are
the us's manufacturing priorities
he will form mobile vaccination units
that would travel to isolated
areas of the country and embark on a
public education
program to combat vaccine denial the
goal will be 100 million shots
administered in 100 days
and for the american people to wear
their masks for the duration of the
president's first 100 days
current president meanwhile was golfing
in florida but also engaging in
political debate
on twitter once again urging the senate
to agree to higher stimulus checks for
low and middle income americans than the
600
already passed by congress is their
objection to the modification
objection is heard the senate majority
leader blocked a vote on the bill that
passed the house of representatives
on monday mandating two thousand dollar
payments
instead he introduced his own bill that
would mandate two thousand dollar
payments
but also the formation of a commission
to investigate allegations of fraud in
the presidential election
and end legal protections for social
media companies
democrats will not vote for such a
package the polls show
overwhelming support for two thousand
dollar checks
now it seems that republican senators
including the two
facing a tough runoff election in
georgia next week that will decide
control of the senate
will be able to say they did vote for
more help with no chance of the money
ever reaching those in need
shihabra tanzi al jazeera washington